tonight law enforcement around the
country investigating a series of brutal
attacks
in several major american cities over
the weekend dozens were shot
some killed and many are blaming the
anti-police
attitude that could inspire a backlash
at the polls
correspondent aisha hosni shows us
tonight from new york
from vicious attacks in broad daylight
to cold blooded murders by night
another summer of sin is already
underway in new york city
shootings here to date are up 81 percent
this weekend alone
27 people were wounded in 22 shootings
including a manhattan federal prosecutor
hit by a stray bullet in the face
while having dinner at a restaurant
bullets went flying in new jersey this
weekend where a birthday party turned
into a mass shooting
14 partygoers were shot two died
community members blame
gang wars chicago had a worse weekend
where
nine people were killed and 38 injured
by gunfire
the victims include a 15-year-old boy
shot in the head
while sitting on a front porch we have a
long way to go
gunfire is up in several major cities
across the country
but pressure continues to mount on
police
in saint louis which has the worst
murder rate in the country
democratic mayor tashara jones is trying
to defund the police by
4 million dollars and shut down a city
jail
and new york's attorney general leticia
james now pushing the police
accountability act
if passed it would limit police officers
discretion
and their ability to use excessive or
deadly force while making it easier to
prosecute officers who do
as officials respond to public outcries
for change
new york times columnist ezra klein
warns democrats
about the political ramifications of
spiking crime
he writes if these numbers keep rising
they could end
any chance we have of building a new
approach to safety
and possibly carry donald trump or
someone like him
back to the presidency in 2024
law enforcement experts laying down a
stark warning of their own
i see skyrocketing gun violence i see
further diminished and
disempowered police
and brett back here in new york state
courts have now fully reopened keep this
date in mind because mayor bill de
blasio of new york city has
long said that crime will start to
decline
as soon as the courts reopen so we'll
watch and see brett
aisha thank you hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else